faites connaissance il vous invitera son
one man show et après le spectacle qui
vous invite à dîner
ils vous révèlent sa sa blessure en fait
c'est à dire son père algérien
ce soir là au fil des eaux file des
verts le personnage s'assombrit il finit
par vous dire qu'il n'est pas programmé
pour vivre vous en déduisez quoi ça
m'émeut évidemment je rentre j'ai
entraîné immédiatement compassion quand
il a bu il vous fait peur
oui ça fait peur parce que quelqu'un qui
boit quelqu'un qu'ils sont en prise
d'une drogue
il n'est plus tout à fait de lui même et
il y avait ces espèces de crise qui
pouvait ressembler à des rien de très
loin celui où tout d'un coup
oui il y avait dès l'été il était
violent
mais c'est vrai qu'ils cassaient tout ça
fait peur
ça fait peur il avait une double
personnalité j'arrête et l'alcool sûrs
et si c'est pas bien et elle s'était pas
bien voyager voilà c'était dans tout le
monde en parle ça vous a choqué ce livre
et cette interview c'est tout à fait je
dirais même outré parce que
c'est présenté jacques comme un monstre
ce qui n'était pas du tout vous savez
que ce livre allait sortir gisèle alors
ce livre je savais qu'ils allaient
sortir mais je savais pas qu'ils
sortiraient sitôt puisque irina m'a
appelé après le décès de jacques donc
même après l'enterrement donc en février
pour me dire effectivement qu'elle
voulait écrire un livre en hommage à
jacques et sur leur grand amour sur leur
bonheur voilà et j'ai été stupéfaite
parce que j'ai vu le livre alors elle
vous a envoyé le livre avant qu'il sorte
moi elle me l'a pas envoyé mais elle
envoyait deux jours avant sa parution à
mes parents avec une dédicace avec toute
mon affection
bien sûr que mes parents ont été
effondré
ce qui se comprend elle a pris contact
avec vous depuis la sortie du livre et
n'arrive rien alors elle a pris contact
avec moi elle est passée dans votre
émission le samedi elle m'appelait le
lundi pour me demander si monsieur
ardisson m'avait contacté ou si je
l'avais contacté rapport à ce que ce qui
avait été dit donc je lui ai raccroché
au nez quand elle dit que votre frère
n'était pas programmé pour vivre c'est
horrible parce que jacques moi je
l'avais régulièrement au téléphone il
était heureux il avait plein de projets
j'ai passé noël avec lui mais par an il
avait beaucoup beaucoup de projets c'est
vrai qu'il a eu une enfance quand même
assez malheureuse assez difficile quand
même un nom il a pas eu une enfance
malheureuse il n'a pas été élevée par
son père géniteur il a il a pu le voir
parce qu'il voulait voir si lui
ressembler donc il était allé en algérie
et l'a vu il m'a dit qu'il l'avait vu de
loin mais qui lui avait pas parlé
il l'a vu une autre fois à paris puisque
son père était venu au théâtre le voir
mais dans la loge pas voir le spectacle
parce qu'il avait besoin que jacques le
lay de niveau financier voilà par contre
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'ils adorent et
ils adorent et mon père et quand elle
dit
et que jacques villeret appris que son
père enfin raymond mais n'était pas son
vrai père elle dit qu'il l'a appris à
l'école
alors non ce sont les parents qui lui
ont expliqué il y avait à peu près sept
ans donc c'est eux qui vont nous
expliquer tous les deux mais pour elle
vit que qu'il a appris à l'école
vous savez je peux pas vous répondre
parce qu'elle dit beaucoup de choses qui
sont un dans lequel intérêt à dire ça
c'est pas je ne sais pas je sais pas en
tout cas là un livre elle a écrit un
livre un livre à vendre donc il faut
bien il faut bien le remplir ce jeu
quand elle dit que jacques a été
enfoncée par son entourage
vous l'avez en france et vous votre
frère anouch jamais non non non non le
seul la seule chose qu'il ya eu c'est
effectivement jacques a été un moment où
on a été
un peu sans se voir parce qu'on l'avait
fait hospitaliser parce que sa santé se
dégrader
puisque effectivement c'est pas un scoop
voilà qu'elle révèle jacques beaucoup bu
mais surtout au moment du divorce parce
que l'on a été vraiment une épreuve
atroce pour lui vraiment et moi je sais
que je l'avais des nuits entières au
téléphone il comprenait pas puisqu'il me
disais c'est comment j'ai pu vivre 20
ans à côté d'une femme qui qui m'a tout
pris kim à tous et ce sont ces termes je
le vois quand elle dit que jacques a été
en français par son entourage parce que
par exemple quand il venait chez vous il
paraît que c'est vous qui lui proposait
de boire des a terrific de boire de
l'alcool
c'est ce qu'elle dit alors que l au
contraire essayé de le retenir
non mais pas du tout moi vous savez j'ai
vécu des temps chez eux puisque j'ai
vécu un moment à paris je les vis des
fois où
chercher à énerver jamais lui disaient
les bois et énerve de toi je les ai vus
donc c'est vrai qu'il la battait non non
alors ça je peux dire que c'est
complètement fou non jacques comme
beaucoup de gens quand il avait bu
pouvait être agressif verbalement mais
comme il avait pu faire certain moment
quand moi je l'avais au téléphone
à côté de ça ça devenait si on rentrait
pas dans son énervement
ça devrait être ça devenait très
théâtral sûr qu'à la limite moi j'ai
finissait même par un sourire en me
disant bon demain ça ira mieux et est
bon aussi le moment quand elle dit que
jacques villeret lui devait son succès
je pense que jacques est suffisamment de
talent pour arriver au succès qu'il a
connu tout seul parce qu'il serait
arrivé avec n'importe quelle autre femme
bien sûr bien sûr dès l'âge de 8 ans il
voulait être acteur
donc il vivait que pour ça parce qu'il
l'aimait vraiment lui oui oui bien sûr
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il a été si
effondré au moment du divorce
ils ont divorcé pourquoi mais parce que
un jour jacques est sorti de chez lui il
s'est trouvé nez à nez lui s'occupait
pas des papiers
il s'est trouvé nez à nez avec un
huissier qui a bien recommandé avec une
tête d'impôts importantes
donc il a demandé il a dit à irin à je
comprends pas qu'est ce que c'est que ça
aille à lui a dit inquiète pas les
impôts ils font des erreurs au niveau de
l'informatique
et puis forcément lui il a été se
renseigner et là il a compris que non
seulement les impôts étaient pas payer
mais l'argent n'était plus là non plus
l'argent n'était plus là pour payer les
impôts non et lui ce jour là il a décidé
de divorcer
c'est à dire qu'il a été un petit moment
où il y croyait pas il nous appelait en
disant mais j'y crois pas c'est pas
possible il ya autre chose je crois pas
et puis il s'est rendu compte qu
effectivement après toutes les démarches
que c'était bien la réalité est là il
s'est effectivement il fonderie qui a
ruiné l'autre parce qu'elle elle dit que
jacques villeret la ruine est ce que
vous entendez celle inverse oui c'est à
dire que je crois qu'elle l'a ruiné
effectivement parce que jacques a quand
même toujours travaillé donc je pense
qu'on sait que un acteur comme lui qui
travaille 30 ans de sa vie se retrouver
sans rien c'est un peu surprenant alors
que j'ai acquis et dépenser de l'argent
c'est bien normal il en gagné parce que
peut aussi dire ça mais à côté de ça il
aurait dû en rester beaucoup et ça il a
recherché ne comprenais pas elle perçoit
de l'argent quand il ya des films de
jacques villeret qui passe la télévision
alors moi je suis pas trop trop au
courant mais je crois qu'elle perçoit
toujours je crois pourquoi elle a décidé
d'après vous ghislaine je comprends pas
bien je comprends pas bien parce que moi
même j'étais surprise mais non c'est je
trouve que c'est le salir et bien sûr il
est plus là pour répondre
donc c'est beaucoup plus facile c'est
con ça à la télévision ajoute a fait
tout à fait pour défendre la mémoire de
votre frère tout à fait parce que nous
on est des gens très discrets et
autrement je veux réparer mais là je
trouve que ça va un peu trop loin
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose à
dire arriver dans villeray ce soir
système simplement qu elle sait ce
qu'elle cesse parce que sinon
effectivement peut-être qu'on se
contentera pas des médias voulaient
attaquer au tribunal pourquoi pas je
sais pas si elle veut aller beaucoup
plus loin oui
bien sûr le témoignage du sol